basically the JK Simmons J jonah Jameson
at the end of far from home is a
grieving father venom 2 :
Flash Thompson is in the middle of a tug
of war between carnage and shriek and
venom and spider-man's way this is all
one movie yes
welcome back sir semolina this is rogue
theory today we're talking about how
spider-man and venom are going to be
maybe new best friends or at least have
some theories are gonna get into joining
us on today's episode are Eric Bob
Angelica Trey and marina Mastro's
alright also in this episode we're gonna
talk about a possible Catwoman storyline
we got Catwoman news about the new
Robert Pattinson Batman movie we'll get
to that later but first guys rogue
theories how would the rumor is that
these two are gonna come together so
Howard venom and spider-man going to
come together Tom Hardy specifically and
the director of the venom movie both
hinted this week that spider-man and
venom are about to appear together in a
movie we thought this might happen
before in the Sony multiverse and we
know there was some sort of agreement so
let's assume that it's gonna happen yeah
what exact story is going to happen okay
so my pictures for Venna
the next venom movie and that the
crossover happens in the next venom
movie - yes venom - not the this is not
a pitch for the next spider-man movie
this is a pitch for the next venom movie
okay and that's where the crossover
happens so basically so Flash Thompson
in far from home is spider-man's friend
he's a little bit of a bully right we
have like a running a bit in that movie
where he's texting his parents and they
never really get back to him but like
he's rich so it's fine like it's fine
Japan Europe yes weird hours thanks rich
parents gave him their number is it hard
for that they're like finally a vacation
but so this this is a running like bit
through the the movie is that his
parents kind of are inattentive right so
my theory is that his parents are
actually scientists and they've both
been working for the life foundation
yeah so that's the crossover or how it
starts right
so they've been working for Life
Foundation both of them they're both
like a you know very experienced smart
scientists and their kids in Europe so
they're like oh he'll be fine
reminder that the light foundation in
venom one is basically the villain of
that movie that is causing all the
symbiote trauma yes
so his parents are working with
symbiotes and they get they do they do
not get infected themselves but they
bring it home okay after the photo shoot
yeah like--on there's a gum in their
briefcase it just crawls out of their
brief yeah yeah yeah and so they bring
it home by accident this is after far
from home happens they bring home by
accident and it does attach itself to
flash so the venom movie is heave it's
venom finds out like oh there's this kid
you know word on the street like he's a
reporter right so he word on the street
is there's this kid who's also been
infected with the same thing I have so
he's like I'm gonna go help this kid I
mean Eddie Brock yeah sorry yeah so he's
like I'm gonna go help this kid you know
deal with this and flash is also getting
convinced to essentially like you know
more or less during the dark side but
you know a different universe by carnage
and shriek because they're also gonna be
in this tree just announced is going to
be in this movie and then carnage
Woody Harrelson we saw in a post-credits
scene for venom and it's basically a tug
of war and and spider-man shows up to
help his friend flash because they you
know he's a little bit of a bully but by
the end of far from home they're cool at
least and he wouldn't abandon him so
they're like he respects one he respects
spider-man but he doesn't like Peter
Parker so then you have spider-man and
venom teaming up to being basically a
tug of war flashes in the middle carnage
and shriek over here being like be bad
be bad eat people and you know
spider-man and venom are over here being
like no no don't eat people all the
venom oh yes that certainly is worth
Rogi that's very plausible I actually
feel like a lot of that could happen
what I'll also wonder right now I'll ask
you is who wins I'm gonna say that
carnage and shriek win because that's
how it sets up the next movie new
quarter oh jeez yeah for you because I'm
a big fan of that add to the villains
yeah I can't make everything worse with
these people that's my dream and just
gonna make it worse
differently from your venom yeah movie
theory I'm thinking it's gonna be in the
next spider-man okay so if we remember
from far from home at the end a
journalist out spider-man yeah and his
identity yes yep so I'm thinking maybe
in the next movie it's gonna be
spider-man 1 and it's gonna be a lot of
journalistic focus okay getting here
yeah and we're gonna see Eddie Brock
come out as maybe like a rogue
journalist this is like a intense deep
action journalism yes it's all gonna be
about hitting yeah all the President's
Men great movie shows the effects of
journalism on yeah and and Tom Hollands
gonna be in it for like two seconds with
my theory I'm thinking maybe Eddie Brock
he starts to sympathize with spider-man
because he hates J Jonas James son
so Eddie Brock hates him and he's venom
during this time and I think maybe he's
going to team up with spider-man at some
point and fight against may be an
ultimate villain in this movie and I'm
thinking maybe something like I don't
know the sinister six it's the route
were their enemies yeah then maybe we
can really build a villain eyes jenna
jameson and there are many stories where
he's actually the whole creation of
either the sinister six or certain
villains are created by him in order to
take down spider-man yeah so he
definitely could be the person that is
the mastermind behind bringing in all
these villains so gotta get in Eddie
Brock what a personal reason but you
know what the personal reasons already
there you think about it the beginning a
venom one of the astronauts on the light
foundation spaceship was John Jameson
writes his son that is JK Simmons who is
dead now and so like basically the JK
Simmons Jay jonah Jameson at the end of
far from home is a grieving father who
is probably like the light foundation
covered up that whole accident like you
know what I'm gonna go into conspiracy
theories to try to like figure out what
happened to my son and if he finds out
that like Eddie Brock has this symbiote
attached he's gonna hate that force you
knows that's what killed his so yeah you
can it laid that death on on Eddie Brock
where is Eddie Brock like you know he's
probably okay I'm Ronan Farrow versus
so Alex Jones like man this guy for
other reasons
right there yeah it's just like all the
pieces you know these movies just have
so much like contents and loose threads
you can actually tie somebody speaking
of foreseen theories okay okay so like
marina my pitches for the next venom
movie because I think they were starting
to put together this venom movie before
Sony and Marvel put together their plan
so I thank you I think the next venom
movie is just going to be a venom and
carnage movie in fact I'm gonna pitch
that the movie title is gonna be venom
Colin maximum carnage because I think
they're gonna be throwing from the
maximum carnage comics series of 1993
which followed Carnage's latest break
out from prison where he's able to like
kind of recreate the carnage symbiote
and he basically has he's like children
that he's puppeting to be other villains
to wreak havoc around Manhattan and that
shriek comes into that story so I think
that's why the fact that shriek is going
to be like his romantic interest I think
they're borrowing from that do a quick
explainer for people who don't know who
shriek is so shriek is a mutant
basically in her skill is - she's like
sonic abilities which is why she's such
a threat to venom because Venom's one
real weakness is like sonic energy and
sonic waves that if you remember there's
that scene in Sam Raimi's spider-man 3
where that's how spider-man is able to
defeat him he uses those poles he hits
them - creepy song sonic waves that
destabilize the the symbiote and in the
venom movie with Tom Hardy that is one
thing that's kind of revealed like a
plane flies over his head and those
sonic waves causes it to kind of freak
out so that's that's one way that you
know you can destabilize the venom so
whales would be a big weakness anything
if everything makes sound screaming a
lot
yeah babies are a big weird thing the
MRI caused him to freak out but MRIs
don't use so we know whose shriek is we
know shriek is so I think that's what
we're gonna see something like that in
venom to venom maximum carnage
I guess the Woody Harrelson's cletus
kasady fighting Tom Hardy venom it's
gonna be just kind of a further
exploration of what we saw in the first
venom where Tom Hardy is a rogue
journalist and he's locked in a battle
with this story subject which is the
serial killer who was broken out of
where was it was it wasn't Rikers it was
San Quentin prison this is the least
rogue but where it's gonna go crazy is
the post which will set up the crossover
with spider-man how because now it's
gonna set up at this point what the
second of the Tom Hollands spider-man
films will be in the MCU which will be a
massive crossover event that will bring
in not just the Fantastic Four and it's
gonna bring in the mutants so in spite
of his amazing friends his roommates his
college roommates are Bobby Drake and
Firestar fire stars actually also part
of the maximum carnage storyline so
we're gonna start to see how the mutants
this is where at the end of phase 4 now
we can see the mutants come into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and it's going
to involve this this massive conflict
where the cletus kasady and envenom are
all gonna be tied in with a sinister six
a carnage and venom and I think the the
big battle the big bad at the end of
phase 4 will be the sinister six
what was the post-credits scene
post-credits scene is going
Carnage's next target is going to be
Peter Parker that's the first hint of
that of that side of the universe so
we're going to see so then the follow-up
movie is having Tom Hardy's venom has to
help save Peter Parker yeah well well
and just to be a bit more specific in
Prague with my idea
imagine like Cletus Kasady they're
losing his battle with with Eddie Brock
venom
is somehow about to murder Jay jonah
Jameson because Jay John Jameson has
somehow got in the middle of that fight
maybe out of revenge for his son's death
and and then he says it's not me the
person you want is this kid and he sees
Peter Parker and he's like oh this is
spider-man picture of this high school
student everyone's just kind of like
that's kind of weird right so that's
gonna set up this next movie and I think
the true crossover will either be that
second spider-man movie where
everything's gonna cross over it's gonna
make endgame look like a mirror team up
movie true Sony spider-man that because
Tom Hollands contract will have expired
they're gonna have a Gwen Stacy or a
Miles Morales that crosses over with
venom and their future that they can
control or Disney will just buy
everything in phase 5 they all get to be
together because somebody doesn't know
in spider-man way this is all one movie
yes I was put here to make people smile
here's a one roadblock for that one
whole thing
say I like that he includes mutants in
it yeah yes I want to point out really
quick that I think marina thinks whales
don't exist and the craziest thing that
could ever happen is a whale they're
huge that's the thing that happens and
they covered on the news they beached
themselves before every time I go whale
watching you don't see them so are they
real all right guys give it back to me
in a tweet okay in a tweet venom 2 :
Flash Thompson is in the middle of a tug
of war between carnage and shriek and
[Laughter]
spider-man closer to home
strike back no that's like multiple
names ah yeah okay
maybe like JJJ or Tolkien yay come on
that was a tough one to say jay jay jay
jonah jameson you almost did it
okay Jay John Jay I got yourself okay
you know what I'll practice it at home
yeah I love how the tweeter supposed to
make these easier to follow really
quickly closer at home is my favorite
part
yeah you're forcing us from being
writers just pitching the opened ideas
to editors having to make sense
hashtag donkey okay so my tweet version
of it is venom maximum carnage bleeds on
to Peter Parker and his mutant friends
[Applause]
baloney baloney I feel like of all of
those the final additional one that I'll
give it to who still marinas actually
because that one it was the easiest to
follow just pretty soon those two we're
gonna cross over and they're gonna team
up and I love it
but I'm also really excited to hear what
you guys have to say about how zoe
kravitz is cat long is gonna come into
the Batman universe but real quick
thanks to our sponsors do you sometimes
get stressed out or maybe feel some
anxiety or like me some chronic pain or
even if you have trouble sleeping once a
week guys you're not alone a lot of
people have some of that going on I
legitimately have a lot of shoulder pain
that I try to work through every single
day especially when I'm working out and
I've been using feels it's premium CBD
that's delivered directly to your
doorstep feels naturally helps reduce
stress anxiety pain and sleeplessness I
take it every single day and it's
totally replaced my dosage of ibuprofen
that I was taking every day I don't need
it at all anymore because I actually can
finally move my arms without feeling
that pain and legitimately it's just
this DVD that's doing it all you have to
do is place a few drops of feels under
your tongue and you feel the difference
between minutes I do it as soon as I
roll out of bed in the morning it's
super easy if you're new to CBD it's not
a big deal feels offers a free CBD
hotline and text message support to help
guide your personal experience it works
super naturally to help you feel better
there's no high or hangover or addiction
or anything like that so join the fields
community to get deals delivered to your
door every month you'll save money on
every order and you can pause or cancel
it at any time
feels legitimately has me feeling my
best every single day and it can help
you to become a member today by going to
Beals comm slash rockstars and you'll
get 50% off your first order with free
shipping that's f e ALS comm slash
rockstars to become a member and get 50%
automatic
they'd taken off your first order with
free shipping feels calm slash rock
stars good news came out this week that
zoe kravitz has been cast as
specifically Selina Kyle okay
theoretically yeah Catwoman yeah a lot
of cat women before and different Batman
properties it's actually one of the most
representative characters actually in
live-action and it's so good and also
Halle Berry even though I really like
her but this this is supposed to be
she was also storm which is the same
level of good alright guys this is must
be a grounded detective movie though we
haven't really seen yeah they keep
describing there's more so what is
catwoman's character and storyline in
this upcoming Batman movie go rogue
please okay well okay here's the brokest
version of Catwoman I can think of one
who is not like a batshit crazy sex pot
who what if she's just like an
established stable veterinarian who
works a lot with cats and nursing them
back to health so we're thinking on
opposite Aaron is not the opposite of
sex Claude they're quite aligned if I'm
gonna trust my pet in the hands of
veterinarian I don't want one who's
super horned up in that moment properly
sexless themselves have been spayed and
neutered
imagine if it's a detective story I
imagine Robert Pattinson to be a
detective it's like an episode of Law &
Order you go from location to location
location and we gather evidence and then
it leads you to the truth which is
something dark and you probably did it
yourself
no in this case he's going to an old
source an old contact of his which is
Selina Kyle and the reason I bring that
up is she's been cast as Selina Kyle
which all the news you know headlines a
and Catwoman's been cast
it's just Selina Kyle what if she's just
Selina Kyle
she's never been Catwoman her she she
used to be Catwoman like stealing to go
to vet school yeah I really liked about
Marvel's Jessica Jones on Netflix is
that she used to be a superhero yeah and
now she's just like a private eye so
imagine a Selina Kyle that's somehow in
that kind of world
but she's just trying to move on and
live her life and Robert Pattinson
Batman Bruce Wayne's draggin her back
into the mister in the drama and she
becomes her life gets threatened as a
result of being implicated in this
mystery really like a lot of that kind
of bad version I wish was Michelle
Pfeiffer but I wouldn't that be cool
like they return to her and she's just
like older and she's like yeah I used to
be able to fit in that insane house
no I'm just caring about these animals
yeah maybe in this one she's not like
the Michelle Pfeiffer the Catwoman who
was like resurrected via cat we're gonna
start a new chat cat person she's got
the cat suit under her so retired
Catwoman is pulled back in yes find
Batman yeah okay I'm into it all right
well I was thinking a little bit more
along the lines of maybe it's like right
before she becomes Catwoman or something
like that but since this is so new are I
always think of Dark City but I think
she's gonna show up as like a femme
fatale character I think she's going to
just like appear in it she's gonna have
some coiffed hair like a problematic
lifestyle where something's going on but
what coiffed hair means it's like oh
it's good and it's like it doesn't go
all the way in a curl but it's waved
it's like yeah okay that's why keep is
Erik's hairstyle in high school you know
when you see it yeah boys getting
together we bring up a picture of Eric
from high school or
I did not hear coiffed I know you quit
sorry
now can you what does that look like
after he did the queefing in detail
going to probably be a damsel in
distress
I think and she's gonna show up with
some issues and then she's probably
going to like Robert Pattinson Batman is
going to find out that she's a little
more dangerous than she seems so are we
still doing are we doing the straight up
its a noir film the damsel shows up at
the beginning but really maybe is
actually behind the crime itself exactly
no that's exactly or maybe like some
sort of peripheral part of the crime or
maybe she's causing her own havoc
without without spoiling it because I'm
starting to feel more and more like this
might be what they do you might be
pitching hush and we've been other weeks
also have been talking about large and
Catwoman and Batman they're romantic
sparks start up in hush at least in one
version of the romantic sparks that's
where it kind of comes from and it
definitely has this weird question of is
she a victim or she partially involved
and it ends and of in a very it has a
little like kind of a post-credits thing
but you just never really know so you
match it hush on hush they say when they
say hush in the comic that's what you
say right before you kiss someone so
yeah whenever you're ready we're all
down hush okay let you know when I'm
ready yeah so I think she's definitely
gonna be along those lines because
Catwoman's always bend that sort of gray
area chaotic neutral what is she gonna
do next and I think this is a great spot
for her to
like lay in this movie yeah maybe it'll
be the gray costume from the animated
series I was thinking more like a deep
cut with the satin and the long sleeves
but okay sure white hair
yeah an unwashed veterinarians lab coats
because she's working so hard an Aryan
to see dn't michelle pfeiffer at the
beginning of the batman movie when she
was cattlemen in it she was there like
receptionist or an assistant and she had
that super ferocious horse the sweaters
all the villainesses of those early era
Batman movies always frazzled yeah
definitely okay so my pitch is that
Selina Kyle is the daughter of a crime
boss and so back in time the crime boss
is married to her mom right there
together and finally you know what her
mom gets sick and tired of this
neglectful husband and she takes her
daughter and she gets a divorce like the
strong woman that she is and so Selena
Kyle grows up in a household with just
her mom and she doesn't find out until
later because her mom wants to keep her
away from this life of crime right she
just wanders like oh like gosh I wonder
who my dad was like did it up but she
eventually finds out when she's a
teenager like Oh your dad is actually
this huge crime boss and the reason that
you don't have a dad and the reason that
you are isolated from the rest of your
entire family is because of crime so her
mother who is a strong single
independent woman leaves that man gets a
career does her own thing and raises her
daughter to do the same so Selina Kyle
has been she's now a geneticist she's
very smart and capable and independent
and she
this is where the only part where the
cat thing comes and is that she's a
geneticist and she's in charge of the
entire program to keep rare cats alive
and breeding successfully like she like
when they take one cat from the zoo and
to another zoo like she's basically in
charge of like keeping wild cats species
diverse and and present and not
endangered anymore so she's very
respected in her field and the only
other kind of like it's not it's very
like realistic but the only other kind
of superpower that she maybe has that
they'll just like allude to no it's like
you know Princess Jasmine just like kind
of has a connection with Raja like she
can control cats she can't control cats
but like she's the big cat sense like
she just says good energy so like if
she's ever in trouble which doesn't
really happen a lot because it's a zoo
situation but like they'll just be down
for her but you definitely are setting
up a action sequence where they come to
get her at the last second just like
poison ivy
okay more like realistic and less like
maybe can't be than that but it's like
that's almost really realistic they kill
her - yeah
so because she's a geneticist what if
she like can she like inject herself was
like cat juice she can what she doesn't
like to do it if she has her super cat
just in her and then she got cat juice
in her brain and it makes it things like
cat and Selena Cal run into each other
because she on the side is now pissed at
her crime boss dad right so she's her
says carmine Falcone yeah sure okay now
I feel better so she's been like on the
side her night job like messing up his
crime syndicate and they don't know who
it is because she's very good okay and
then Batman runs into her while they're
both trying to fight the same crime and
he's like um who's this and she's like
bye
cuz she has her own thing going on she's
a very independent lady well she's a
geneticist saving deserve me when I'm a
tiger either she sprouts a tail and uses
it to fight crime
guys the only theory here that I think
is worthy of a blog I'm sorry is
Angelica's others are worthy of all
kinds of adjectives being thrown at them
I think only only yeah I wasn't just
because of weird a thing that we may
have cut from this episode but also
because it's the most in line with what
I like we said with hushes it's
everything is me I mean towards this
like more film and she's in there and
also I just don't want her to be just a
better Mary
don't like the wrassle I want a happy
life first Selina Kyle
I like that too but I really like the
thing where why can't she have a happy
life you don't even like no matter what
she tries it's still okay um no you know
what Eric I'm sorry you can have yeah I
do like your idea but you're my favorite
this time but there's still ways to make
up points remember that way right
whoever gets the most roadies by the end
of this gets a wish to come true oh
because you came up special let's go
ahead and build it up and say real like
these tweets are gonna be real good
Angelica what's your 200 yeah
the Batman : feline femme fatale oh
that's very good that man let me have my
partial act not acronym what's the
regeneration thank you there we go D
feel better
good yeah carmine Falcone E's daughter
is Selina Kyle also she has Princess
Jasmine powers alive Mike is just a
video from the dodo my wish is that Eric
with commitment but remember this can
all go totally out the window because
you get so many roadies right now off of
these Road questions these are questions
that we haven't seen we have no idea
what they're about to be but the answers
are gonna be pretty broke are you ready
yes yes brie Larson revealed last week
that she's never watched any YouTube
videos about Captain Marvel how offended
should Eric be 100% offended yeah okay
well I feel like I should take the
opposite of this now just not offended
okay cuz it might it might ruin her her
character being in character I'm sure
there's a there's a lot of romance one I
bet with like romance like Wonderwall
over it you know I think you should be a
millennial watching one of their
favorite childhood stand-ups do a new
comedy no rogue ease on that zombieland
double tap comes out this week and in it
the heroes explore an abandoned white
house where's the first place you're
exploring after the zombie apocalypse oh
I know you go to answer whatever you go
to the UCLA library and you board it all
up so that nobody else can get in
because all the knowledge in the world
is kept in there and you can do whatever
you want for the future you could
survive you can learn how to build
anything you want and it's also from the
book earth abides and everyone hates
mansur but it's very smart I was like is
there food in there food I want to do
like a tour of like scented food they're
made of trees so I'm thinking maybe like
a tour of celebrity mansions Oh cute I
think that'd be really fun and then you
can like raid their pantry and stuff
that's already which celebrity I'm
thinking like the weirdest one like
possibly fun like I like a Charlie Sheen
moment
yeah yeah not someone that's only gonna
have like expired juices in their fridge
though honestly Gwyneth Paltrow's might
be pretty fun to raid though what are we
gonna find in here
yogurt that you should not eat yeah
really
so I would go to galaxy's edge and I
would go to Disney which you know I can
go there right now but I don't want
anybody there I don't want any of the
rights to be working I don't want any
food to be eatable I want it to be
rat-infested I want zombies to be trying
to push the rides and grind them along
the tracks myself because electricity
this is where Eric reveals that he would
just put on all the character costumes
and Bethenny would exist in yet okay Tom
B apocalypse will cut me saying this but
I totally expected in this that's
amazing it was getting into a dark place
yeah it's you you're in the mind palace
really dark room and
I'm worried about you also Angelica I'm
giving you one because it was good
enough for a movie and then I don't
believe you know you could eat the books
but it could all it all be figured out
right he has last road question guys
Chris Hemsworth's said this week that he
wants to remake the film the three
amigos with Robert Downey jr. and Chris
Evans not a question yet the three white
guys I guess that's my yeah what other
80s movie do you want to see them team
up for instead I want to see weird
science where Downey plays the same
character he played Downey plays the
sexy model that they make creature
that's great yeah I'm just thinking
ghostbusters right now I wasn't in the
well a long forgotten it's about time
for an all-male ghost what about a
monster squad great answer and a third
Rogie sum up our totals I have three
point two five what is that you sure
yeah three point two five I have three
three I have three point two six because
of how I measure it you guys both way
and you guys tied so we'll get both of
us
Angelica's yours will be shredded
immediate Eric's wish is that everyone
including Eric this just means something
usually must talk like Shrek for the
rest of you donkey marinas wish new rock
stars has to tweet that I was she was
right about the end of without spoiling
just that she was right it we won't
include any spoilers for my prediction
was right it was right pictures up there
to prove it that's right Mary Amos
theories are like onions okay hey now
you're rock stars for watching thanks
for going rogue without a tray you can
say the rest of you okay don't forget to
subscribe to rogue theory podcast feed
and stitch you into YouTube channel for
this and other shores follow us on
Twitter at new rock stars for Melina
alright
[Music]